the Joe Rogan experience when did you
get into kung fu movies
wow I got a nose like I saw my first
kung fu movie I think at the age of nine
right wow you know that's probably only
my third movie experience Wow only
because you know right I mean nowadays I
see movies anyway back then and early
seventies it'll go somewhere you got to
go somewhere and listen clear I have a
tape oh no no no no no no this is this
before VHS I'll talk about going to the
movies and movie let me give you a
little movie history for the RZA first
movie I ever saw was uh Huckleberry Finn
okay
down south my cousin took me to the
movies I was maybe six or seven years
old second time to the movie theater
second time my uncle Hollis took me it
was a double feature with Star Wars and
the swarm right mr. ty all this stuff
affects my life the killer bees the
swarm
lieutenant killer bees right third time
to the movie theater right or third or
fourth time because I saw Rocky and then
I saw a double feature starring Bruce
Lee which is called Philly of the Dragon
and another movie I saw that I was
hooked on action kung fu movies as a
double feature you had to the double
feature ten days of nine and mind you
how was the birth of wu-tang clan and
mind you back then to go to the movies
you did with my family didn't have the
dollar 25 like to get the money to go to
the movies that's a big deal may take
six months and we got to the movies I'm
telling this family my family this is
back when I was still eating meat pork
swine you know he's too chill the pig we
still raise them name them kill them eat
them all right but so now I'm in New
York City live on my grandmother send me
the movies
Rocky's playing everybody's coming to
see rocky we got to bring our Sunday
dinner to the theater with us Oh [ __ ]
she stuffed pig feet something Oh
collard greens but oh wow in the movie
is let you bring it in you know what you
also you once you had a big bag you know
the big bag was yeah yeah this nobody
was thirsty one [ __ ] might get a
soda
yeah yo let me tell you something we
walked for years I walk right past all
the concessions yeah everything popcorn
hot dogs Twizzlers
never had the money for that [ __ ] walked
straight in the field yeah I'm with
because listen think about a dollar for
a snicker you can't even get a snicker
when was 46 nope
like you said actually Lisa oxide Paris
hey mom you got 25 cent was just say boy
ain't got good sense ain't got no sag
got good sense boy loved it so we for
that ever but at the end of the date of
those movie moments you know I mean they
really inspired me really took me like
to a world I was different from the from
the project world that I lived in you
know I'm a hmm
and once I start seeing movies like the
five deadly venoms and 36 chambers and
mask Avengers and super ninjas all that
we start seeing those now you'd like in
a preview yes it seen all this accident
is this you start resonating with me
[Applause]